12 días de diplomacia que buscan cambiar
el panorama climático actual los líderes
de la conferencia internacional sobre el
clima de la ONU la cop27 tienen retos
monumentales este año varios países de
Asia tuvieron inundaciones devastadoras
África Oriental está sumida en una
sequía que profundiza los altos niveles
de hambruna y Europa vivió las de calor
sin precedentes la cop 27 debe ser el
lugar para cerrar la brecha de ambición
La Brecha de credibilidad y la brecha de
solidaridad debe volver a ponernos en el
camino correcto para reducir las
emisiones e impulsar la resiliencia y
las adaptaciones climáticas en la
Organización meteorológica Mundial
alertó que los últimos ocho años van en
camino a ser los más cálidos de los que
se tiene constancia y mientras se tiene
el objetivo de limitar el calentamiento
global en 1,5 grados centígrados las
organizaciones ambientales estiman que
si no se aumentan los esfuerzos la
temperatura promedio llegará a 2,8
grados centígrados para finales de siglo
algo a lo que se suma la cuestionada
voluntad de grandes países emisores de
Carbón pues tan solo 29 de los 194
países que forman parte de la convención
sobre cambio climático han actualizado
sus objetivos para reducir emisiones
en contraste la Cumbre inició con una
noticia positiva la inclusión del tema
de pérdidas y daños en la agenda oficial
de la conferencia de las partes algo que
los países en desarrollo venían
solicitando desde hace bastante tiempo
lo confirmó samesucre quien asumió este
domingo como presidente de la cop27
recibo con especial satisfacción el
acuerdo de las partes de incluir un
nuevo tema en la agenda sobre acuerdos
de financiación para responder a
pérdidas y daños esto crea por primera
vez un espacio institucionalmente
estable en la agenda formal de la Cup y
el acuerdo de París para discutir temas
apremiantes de los acuerdos de
financiación necesarios para abordar las
brechas existentes en la respuesta a
pérdidas y daños
dentro de los pendientes todavía está el
compromiso de los países desarrollados
de entregar 100 mil millones de dólares
al año para adaptación y mitigación de
los efectos del cambio climático